20th anniversary of 9 11 and the
majority of americans don't feel safe
from the terror threat
just 49 see the united states is more
secure than it was before the attacks
that's down from 64 percent a decade ago
maybe this is why president biden's
botched afghanistan withdrawal and the
taliban's return to power could turn the
war-turned country back into a terrorist
safe haven and dhs secretary mayorkas
says that while there's no credible
threat
well he's still concerned we've seen the
threat evolve from the foreign
terrorists seeking to enter the united
states to the individual here
radicalized to violence by a foreign
terrorist ideology to now what we
consider the most serious
terrorism-related threat on our homeland
which is the domestic violent extremists
so am i concerned yes i'm concerned
today i'm concerned tomorrow and i was
concerned yesterday
well doug is not too concerned because
he's the border is wide open and
people are just pouring across so he can
save that why do you think the american
people are
more concerned at this point because
everything that this administration
touches it turns into chaos i think
that's the word that greg has used over
and over again the
you know what just sounding like you
drank half a bottle of benadryl doesn't
make us feel good when the world is
spiraling out of control it's not only
to keep us safe their jobs it's to make
us feel safe and if you look at it's
what happened in afghanistan clearly but
it's also how they have not stood up to
china on the wuhan virus tony blinken
met with a chinese official in march and
sat there and let that official lambast
him about the sins of america and he was
like didn't do anything didn't say
anything so when is biden going to stand
up to china on the wuhan virus and by
the way you can connect the two because
al qaeda was running bio weapons labs 20
years ago they probably learned
something from the what four and a half
million people who have died worldwide
because of a single virus that spread
around was more than
650 000 americans so that's why people
are utterly freaked out and it's not
just republicans dana and the poll says
independents and democrats also much
more concerned yeah so independents are
fickle voters usually they
pretty much don't like either political
party so they like to and basically they
don't like washington
but what you would hope is that they
could at least trust washington you can
dislike but still um hope i do think
actually
on the merits the united states is safer
today than it was on september 10 2001.
there's a couple of reasons one
this is kind of it's unbelievable to
think about now but at the time it was
illegal
for the intelligence community and law
enforcement to share information with
each other you as you think back on like
what in the world how could that have
possibly happened that changed in the
patriot act and even though it's still
not perfect at least that does make us
safer but still two things are true they
were true then and they're true now
which is the terrorists only have to be
right once right and
um
you know that could be with a weapon of
mass destruction or not but they only
have to be right once we have to be
right every single time that means we
have to have a committed focus on this
the second thing that's still true is
that this is a generational war on
ideology so you have to fight it from
various different perspectives i think
you have to stay on offense and i wonder
if the american people just feel like
right now that they feel like we are on
defense and that doesn't feel good i
don't think that's necessarily true but
again it is also how you feel uh
congressman michael waltz today
who said that the afghanistan under the
taliban is now a terrorist super state
and josh croshar of national journal i
highly recommend his column today about
the politics about all of this um you
could see a return of the security moms
of 2004 because yes the economy is
critically important but if you do not
feel secure that's your that's your
first priority um soccer moms security
moms a lot of moms greg yep yep yeah so
if afghanistan
is a terror state then that makes us the
world's largest sponsor of terror with
like 30 billion dollars worth of weapons
we just yeah um so majorca said uh is
that his name
close my york is just the first place to
go it is i get confused he said there's
no credible threat unless it's you know
a white supremacist in face pain so i
you wonder why is it that when the
democrats enter power
we instinctively feel less safe it's
that reason because we've met the enemy
and to them it's always going to be us
you know we've had terror under both
parties uh but we feel like the dems are
always more concerned about our phobic
response to it right so whenever there
was like something awful that would
happen
and a beheading or a terror attack
the fox would cut the fox the fox fox
news would cover it but other cable
channels would be obsessed with
islamophobia so the phobic response then
of the actual isis attacks which is why
they always often denied the signs of
organic terror of of converted islamic
radicals um so i don't know maybe when
if al qaeda decides to attack they will
identify as white supremacists which by
the way is cultural appropriation which
it would be the probably the most
offensive thing about it to the hard
left progressives got to worry about bio
terror cyber terror and what was the
last one attacks on our grid that's the
new thing i don't think it's going to be
like the 911 or or those types of
spectacles but it could be something far
more sinister even more destructive if
they could shut down a country
jessica
okay um
thank you
uh
yes uh shutting down the grid this
happening i mean this is leon pandata
has been talking about this for a long
time now that we're not going to have
traditional warfare anymore and we're
starting to see that certainly from
china and russia and iran and we'll see
kind of how the middle eastern players
get into this in terms of the drop
of feelings of security from 64 a decade
ago down to 49 today around 9 11 things
do get a little antsier for people you
just can't help but be reminded of
what's going on it's obviously across
every paper you open any channel you
turn to but now we have 911 plus right
we have these images of what's going on
actually in a hub of islamic extremist
terror and that's really compounding
things for people and greg's mentioned a
few times that this was a story that
people could largely turn away from over
the past few years i mean foreign policy
nuts are obviously thinking about it all
the time and it certainly mattered but
now there is no escaping
basically our worst national nightmare
which is what 9 11 was and i think that
that's a very tough thing for a lot of
people especially heading into the 20th
anniversary um and it is informing how
secretary maiorcus who maybe likes
mayorka uh is talking about what's going
on so you have the domestic threat which
has been huge and prevalent the past few
years compounded now with a new
foreign threat that we hadn't thought
about in a long time can i just add one
i want to thank andy mccarthy he's
talked to me a lot on the phone and he
is dismayed
and he covered a lot of points talking
to me that dana did but he's dismayed
that we seem to be repeating what we did
30 years ago and he said they don't
understand the jihadist enemy and they
refuse and to greg's point that
conservatives get treated as if they're
evil because we refuse to coddle the
enemy that is being sheltered by the
left
all good points except for me